well anna after days of confusion and
frankly ministers contradicting each
other sky news now has an understanding
of the shape of what's to come on the
cost of living crisis from the
government's point of view over the next
few weeks and months and i now
understand that there is an expectation
in government that ministers will be
able to offer new help make a big
announcement before the summer recess
now that help could entail tax cut it
could also entail more specific help
with energy bills of the sort that we
saw earlier in the year the precise
details have of course not been decided
this far out but what that does i
believe is put the chancellor and the
prime minister back much more on the
same page after yesterday where the
chancellor uh seemed to resist
suggestions that the prime minister
would offer help within days now i
suspect they're both
working on the same time scale after
massive pressure from tory mps of the
sort that you were hearing in that film
now will it be enough we're going to
have to wait and see there will be more
tensions of course boris johnson's
instincts always to spend and spend big
at times like this rishi sunak made no
secret of his worries about the cost of
interest debt interest which has reached
recent record highs so a lot unresolved
but sky news tonight now does expect an
announcement on the cost of living
potentially involving tax cuts before
the july end of july recess